hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast using radiotherapy tumor
reactive monoclonal antibodies and il-2
to engage in Nate and adaptive
anti-tumor immunity presented by dr.
Paul Sandow professor Pediatrics
department of human oncology and
genetics University of wisconsin-madison
I'm Xavier Gutierrez of lab rats and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Sandow I will now turn the presentation
over to him
hello I'm Paul sandal thank you for
joining us today we're going to be
focusing on how we can be combining
various forms of therapy to engage both
the innate and adaptive immune systems
they have a beneficial anti-tumor effect
I work here at the University of
Wisconsin as shown here I'm involved in
a variety of collaborations but none of
these involve any financial conflict of
interest this is a schema of where
cancer immunotherapy currently is in
2018 a number of different cell types
are involved on the major focus of the
cancer immunotherapy clinical
application is focused on the adaptive
component of the immune system namely
turning on t-cells ability to recognize
tumour peptides presented by the MHC
molecule on tumor cells in order to
destroy them and this approach has had
quite a bit of success in select kinds
of cancers in addition there is a
separate kind of immunotherapy that is
also having quite a bit of success this
is the synthetic recognition that can be
allowed by utilizing not the immune
systems own endogenous recognition
capability but rather passively applied
synthetically created molecules like
monoclonal antibodies made in the
laboratory to help direct and dodging as
immune cells like natural killer cells
or to modify immune cells like t-cells
and turn them into chimeric antigen
receptor t-cells these approaches have
met with a fair amount of success
recently particularly in tumors that are
difficult for the adaptive immune system
to recognize specifically there's been
great progress in pediatric leukemia and
certain solid tumors we think that the
future and what we'll be talking about
today is how to tie together these two
kinds of
recognition both synthetic and adaptive
in order to try and maximize the ability
of the immune system to recognize and
destroy cancer for therapeutic benefit a
disease model that I'll be speaking
about to some component in this talk is
that of pediatric neural blastoma the
concepts presented in this talk however
don't apply only to pediatric disease
are only two neuroblastoma neuroblastoma
is the most common solid tumor in
children that occurs outside of the
brain this graph shows that roughly half
of children with neuroblastoma at the
time of diagnosis have high risk disease
and up until nine years ago the
prognosis of these children using very
aggressive combination modality therapy
was still on the order of only 30% and
so our team and many others were focused
on how might we use the immune system to
help the prognosis of those children dr.
Jackie Hank in our laboratory began
testing a monoclonal antibody that we
received from Ralph Riceville shown here
this antibody now calls Dyna tux Amell
is a monoclonal antibody that recognizes
the dice ILO ganglia side gd2 that is
overexpressed on neuroblastoma on
melanoma on certain other pediatric
solid cancers and certain other adult
sarcomas and lung cancer our focus was
neuroblastoma and what dr. Hanks showed
in the laboratory is if she coats
neuroblastoma cells with this antibody
the antibody by itself
doesn't kill the neuroblastoma at all
but if she activates human natural
killer cells with a potent immune
activator interleukin 2 which itself was
approved in 1998 as an immunotherapy for
melanoma and renal cell cancer
it caused dramatic activation of human
natural killer cells and those natural
killer cells were able to kill
the antibody coated tumour cells so
there was a clear synergy the graph at
the top shows that we could make this
work with blood from healthy donors but
if we took blood from patients with
cancer and tested them they didn't work
in this in vitro system very well but if
we took those same patients with cancer
and gave them in vivo interleukin 2 it
activated their natural killer cells so
that now they could kill neuroblastoma
cells in the setting of this monoclonal
antibody and IO 2 we then took that
concept and asked could we move this
first through in vitro testing then
through Mouse testing and then into
initial phase one level clinical trials
and with help from several collaborators
we were able to test this concept in
adults with melanoma here at the UW
Cancer Center and in children with
neuroblastoma through our work in the
Children's Oncology Group in brief we
tested patients by giving them
interleukin 2 together with anti gd2
monoclonal antibody to try and simulate
what we had shown in vitro we learned a
lot about pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics but sadly very few
patients were showing clinical benefit
we went back to the drawing board and
determined that when this approach was
used in mice it had the most potent
effects if we were treating mice that
had only minimal amounts of cancer in
them enough cancer that without
treatment these mice would all die based
on that we felt that this approach might
be best treating patients who were in
remission but at high risk for relapse
secondly if activating natural killer
cells with il-2 to induce antibody
dependent cell killing by the monoclonal
antibody we thought getting other cells
involved that could mediate that same
process through their FC receptors cells
like macrophages and neutrophils would
make sense and preclinical work being
done by Nikon Cheung as
sloan-kettering and Alice you at the
UCSD
were showing the gm-csf an activator of
those neutrophils and macrophages could
induce a DCC using the same antibody so
the Children's Oncology Group group
initiated a clinical trial randomizing
patients that were in remission after
combined chemotherapy surgery radiation
therapy and autologous transplant to put
these neuroblastoma patients into
remission and once they were in
remission they were randomized to
receive this complex immunotherapy
regimen
il-2 gm-csf and anti gd2 antibody the
study began in 2003 and in 2009 our
statisticians called us and said we
needed to stop the study because the
study had passed the statistical
threshold for study cessation the data
shown here showed that at that time with
only about 60% of the patients entered
into the study that we thought would be
needed we had passed the threshold with
a p-value of 0.01 to drumming that the
patients receiving the immunotherapy had
a dramatically improved in vent free
survival compared to those that we're
not getting the immunotherapy based on
that this work was published in 2010 in
the New England Journal and five years
later in 2015 this regimen and this anti
gd2 antibody now renamed Dino toxin map
was approved by the FDA as the treatment
of choice for children with high risk
neuroblastoma that achieve remission and
this same regimen was approved the
subsequent year as the treatment of
choice for patients in Europe so this
was clearly a step in the right
direction and is now the standard of
care but even with that improvement you
can see that we need to do much better
because too many children that are
getting this regimen are still dying so
we know that this anti tumor approach
is working through both the gm-csf and
il-2 and the antibody dependent
cell-mediated cytotoxicity and that ADCC
effect is mediated largely by natural
killer cells so one of the things we
wanted to ask is might we be able to use
some precision medicine approach to
understand which cells are involved in
which patients might be more likely to
benefit from this immunotherapy than
others so the actual killer cells are
regulated in their response by so-called
killer immunoglobulin like receptors
tear molecules I'm oversimplifying here
but these ki are molecules are largely
inhibitory molecules and the ligands
that they see are the HLA molecules on
normal tissues or on tumor cells and
when these cure receptors see those HLA
molecules the natural killer cells are
turned off what's shown in this slide is
that roughly forty percent of the human
population inherits their cure genes
which are controlled by the 19th human
chromosome in such a way that they have
key receptors that are matched for all
of their HLA molecules which are
controlled by the sixth chromosome
these people are so-called peer matched
or self matched patients the remaining
60% of the population have inherited a
cure repertoire such that they have at
least one inhibitory cure gene that does
not see a corresponding lagging a
corresponding HLA molecule and that's
what's shown at the bottom these people
are so-called cure self mismatch and
these people have somewhat more potent
NK cells because at least some of their
NK cells are not being hidden inhibited
by the HLA so past studies have shown
that patients that are this cure self
mismatched have slightly bent
function in the setting of allogeneic
bone marrow transplant and we asked
whether there might be some possible
connection of them in the setting of
care interactions with the immunotherapy
that I just showed you so on the next
slide
doctors Amy herb eager a Lin Wei wang
looked at this care matched versus Kier
mismatched issue for patients that were
in this large clinical trial that I
showed you that we published in the New
England Journal of Medicine and we did
the Kier Kier ligand genotyping of all
of these patients they asked might these
genes in any way influence the response
to the immunotherapy
here are the data that we obtained this
is a somewhat complex slide that I'll
simplify in the next two slides but what
we're looking at here is the overall
survival of the patients in that
randomized trial the patients that were
randomized to receive immunotherapy are
shown with the black lines the patients
that did not receive the immunotherapy
are shown with the red lines the
patients that have the Cure ligand
missing genotype are the dashed lines
and the patients that have the cure
ligands present are shown in the solid
lines and it's a little easier if you
look at this in the next slide so here
we're just showing those patients that
did or didn't get immunotherapy and had
the cure ligands missing and you can see
that these patients a hundred and
eighteen out of a hundred and seventy
four patients so about 65 percent or so
of our patient population have this
genotype and it looks like for them the
immunotherapy didn't seem to make a
difference
in contrast the next group we're looking
at roughly 35 percent of our patients
these are the ones that have the cure
ligands present and for them it looks
like the immunotherapy is making a very
major difference for them now this work
has only been looked at in the
way in there's one randomized trial
we're in the process of collecting
patient samples from additional
neuroblastoma patients to compare those
that got immunotherapy and those that
didn't to see if this is validated but
this would be an example of where one
could use this potential genotyping
information to potentially determine
which patients might best benefit from
this form of immunotherapy
and for those that might not benefit
from this form to be using some other or
expanded kind of therapy to try and help
their overall survival so that's a
hypothesis that's yet to be tested but
overall when we look at the data from
that randomized trial we see there are
two areas that we really need to improve
on the first shown by the blue arrow is
for those patients that were randomized
when they were in remission to receive
the immunotherapy and glad got the
immunotherapy shown by the black line
and even amongst those patients roughly
45 to 50 percent are still relapsing of
their neuroblastoma it means we need to
do better even though this immunotherapy
regimen is helping but separately and
more difficult to see is in order to get
this immunotherapy those patients needed
to enter remission following their
initial induction chemotherapy radiation
surgery and autologous bone marrow
transplant and as you can see from the
green arrow about 30 percent of newly
diagnosed hirez neuroblastoma patients
don't enter remission and therefore
didn't even receive this kind of
immunotherapy because our preclinical
data say that it wouldn't be of help to
them so there are a number of approaches
listed in the bottom left that are being
used to try and make an impact on those
two areas one is combining this kind of
immunotherapy with chemotherapy another
is generating chimeric antigen receptor
t-cells that are reacting to GE 2 the
third is to genetically engineer the
monoclonal antibody so it can work
better and the last is to deliver a
local
you know therapy to turn on both in an
eight and an adaptive immune response in
this truck I'm gonna focus on those last
two issues now this is important because
the likelihood of the most common form
of immunotherapy that is being used
clinically namely immune checkpoint and
ambition such as ctla-4 blockade or pd-1
blockade seems to be effective only for
those patients that have so-called hot
tumors tumors that have a high tumor
mutation burden and therefore have a
high level of neo antigens with a high
level of infiltrating t-cells in other
and immune what in other words an immune
response has already bent or not but
most pediatric cancers as shown on the
left and the vast majority of adult
cancers shown in the middle along the
x-axis have relatively low tumor
mutation burdens and are therefore cold
cancers not showing great responses to
immune checkpoint blockade so the
concept behind immune checkpoint
blockade is if you've got lots of neo
antigens and if you've got t-cells that
are trying to respond but just not
effective because the brakes have been
turned on if you take the brakes off
it'll help the endogenous immune system
respond but if your car is parked on the
level and isn't trying to move forward
just taking the brakes off isn't gonna
help unless you can turn the engine on
so we'd like to get the engine turned on
by getting the immune system interested
in the tumor in order to try and help
checkpoint blockade work better so the
next example I'd like to give is
genetically engineered monoclonal
antibodies to try and have a more potent
effect so what's shown at the upper
right of this slide is an anti gd2
antibody like the ones that are being
used clinically it's a humanized
antibody but most importantly at the
lower right of that antibody what
schematized is those blue ovals that's
il-2 it's been directly a genetically
fused is a fusion
fusion protein to these this monoclonal
antibody so this antibody will bind to
the GE 2 on tumors that Express GE - but
it'll bring aisle 2 to the tumor
micro-environment this immuno cytokine
was created by Ralph rice Feld and Steve
gillies and at the lower left you can
see that mice with metastatic
neuroblastoma show huge numbers of liver
metastases if they get PBS as their
treatment if they get treated with the
combination of anti gd2 antibody and
il-2 injected in the same syringe of
separate molecules the number and size
of metastasis is much smaller but
they're still metastases there well if
you give the same molar amounts of that
same antibody in il-2 but now is this
fusion protein this immuno cytokine you
don't see cancer at the lower right st.
Neil in our laboratory tested this
concept in mice that had metastatic
neuroblastoma and showed that the
potency of this immuno cytokine depends
on how much neuroblastoma is there at
the time you start using this treatment
if you start this treatment
11 days or nine days after you implant
the neuroblastoma you still have some
improvement in metastases but not enough
while if you start on day five or
earlier you really eradicate the
metastases so at the upper left you can
see in point for this approach seems to
work as single agent therapy and minimal
residual disease in mice we did a phase
two trial of this same approach in
children with neuroblastoma through the
Children's Oncology Group that trial was
published in 2010 and a repeat trial of
the same concept was published in at the
ASCO meeting in 2015
both of them showing that this fusion
protein works for advanced neuroblastoma
but it works best in patients with less
bulky disease so based on that we're
moving this concept forward but as much
as that might work for minimal residual
disease we
like to try and have an immunotherapy
that can work against measurable disease
because far too many patients aren't
entering remission with their upfront
therapy or are relapsing with measurable
disease before their current therapy is
affected so Eric Johnson and Sasha reg
Malevich in our lab took a GE to
positive melanoma implanted it in the
flank of a mouse let it grow to the
point where it was barely palpable so
it's no longer minimal disease but it's
barely big enough to feel and they were
able to show that if you treat those
mice with the intravenous immunity as
shown in the middle line in this graph
it dramatically slows the growth of the
tumor but the tumors are still grown but
if you put that same amount of the
immuno cytokine directly into the tumor
labeled by ITIC intramural immuno
cytokine now many of the mice were tumor
free and the tumors that we're still
there were growing much more slowly so
Eric was able to show that this was no
longer just an innate immune response
but under this circumstance both innate
cells and T cells and the adaptive
immune response was involved Richard
yang was able to look at this same
phenomenon in a neuroblastoma model and
showed when the immuno cytokine was
injected intramurally he could show
curative responses in mice and show that
both natural killer cells and T cells
were involved in this response you could
show this also in this graph where he
took mice with a palpable neuroblastoma
inject into those mice with the inter
tumor luminal cytokine and showed that
roughly 60% of those mice were cured of
a palpable a neuroblastoma but if he
depleted either the t-cells shown by the
black squares or depleted NK cells shown
by the black triangles he lost this
effect so this is a clear example of
where both innate immune recognition and
adaptive immune recognition both NK
cells and T cells have to be working
together
in order to get this curative response
but here again these tumors are quite
small so since we know t-cells can be
involved can we enhance this response
with checkpoint blockade that helps
activate T cells to function better if
they're initially turned on so sacha
recommend which took this melanoma model
that's a gd2 Mouse melanoma put it in
mice and let it grow for seven days to
the point where it's barely measurable
so it's small but it's still macroscopic
what's shown on the left is that animals
that are getting treated with checkpoint
blockade the red line show no
improvement at all so even though this
immunise I am you know cytokine can have
an effect in the absence of immuno
cytokine the checkpoint blockade isn't
working so this is a colles tumor the
Green Line shows how the immuno cytokine
by itself is dramatically slowing the
growth of these tumors but these tumors
are still growing when both are combined
the immuno cytokine and the anti ctla4
checkpoint blockade the yellow line
shows that there's dramatic slowing of
the growth of these tumors as shown on
the survival curve at the right so from
the perspective of a most study this is
a dramatic success but from the
perspective of clinical immunotherapy
this is not successful enough because
most of these animals are still dying
and if you do this exact same approach
in a tumor that was growing for only 12
days instead of seven days like in the
last slide you can see in this picture
the control untreated tumors of the
black line the tumors that are getting
treated with both the immuno cytokine
and the checkpoint blockade are the blue
line while they're growing slower all of
these animals have tumors that are
growing if this were a clinical Phase
two trial where there wasn't a
randomized control group it would be a
failed trial because all of these
subjects in this trial would be
progressive so clearly we need to do
better and we need to do better with
bigger children so at this point
fortunately enter into the scene
is my colleague Zack Morris an MD PhD
who is a radiation oncologist who worked
in our laboratory on this concept during
his residency and two years ago finished
his residency and began his own
laboratory in the Cancer Center here on
the floor below were still collaborating
closely what Zack did was take these
exact same melanoma cells injected them
into these immunocompetent mice and
instead of letting them grow for seven
days or 12 days they grew for five full
weeks
so these are now large macroscopic
tumors 200 cubic millimeters inside he
took them and he treated with a low dose
of radiation therapy a dose that
wouldn't shrink these tumors that would
only slow their growth to some degree
and then five days later he injected
these tumors with the antibody il-2
immuno cytokine and looked at how this
combination would work and the data are
shown on this next slide at the upper
left are the size of the tumors the gold
line shows how these large tumors
continue to grow if they get no
treatment the green line shows how this
dose of radiation therapy twelve grey
about 1/3 to 1/4 the dose that's used
for palliative purposes in the setting
of melanoma slows these tumors but
doesn't shrink them the black line shows
how the intramural immuno cytokine slows
these tumors but doesn't shrink them and
the purple lines show is really to our
surprise for the first time we've got
these large tumors in these mice that
are now shrinking away and 73% of these
mice became tumor free without any tumor
at all not only after 60 days but for
many months after that and these mice
had a long lasting memory in order to
show that what Zack did was take these
mice that were cured by getting their
radiation therapy at 5 weeks and their
immuno therapy 5 days
and if they had no evidence of tumor ten
weeks after that point they would then
get injected with another dose of that
same melanoma and they would reject it
as shown at the top and those mice that
rejected that same melanoma could then
be injected with a separate email
logically related melanoma the b16 tumor
or an unrelated pancreatic tumor these
mice would reject the v16 tumor because
of the shared antigens between B 16 and
B 78 but they would not reject the
pancreatic cancer we published many
mechanistic studies regarding what's
involved in this immune response and the
bottom-line importance is that we've got
both the need for the innate immune
recognition and the adaptive immune
recognition to get rid of these really
large sizeable tumors as much as we were
excited about those results we didn't
think that was good enough to really be
moving forward clinically because the
real problem with clinical cancer is not
only the cancer you can see but its
distant cancer at other sites that you
might or might not be able to see so
radiation oncologists have long
described this so-called AB Schiphol
effect where very rare individuals might
get radiation at a single site of cancer
and after that radiation as expected if
enough radiation was given that cancer
would shrink but distant sites would
normally continue to grow but in rare
patients with cancer after you radiate a
single site distant sites would shrink
so the applicable effect means getting
an immune effect at a distance site so
in this setting we've got these patients
having distant cancer shrink and it was
long thought to potentially be mediated
by an immunologic mechanism so Zack
Morris in our lab asked might this
process be something we could try and
simulate in the mouse model and get
intentional control of this to try and
make this happen in an intentional and
clinically controllable way so Zack set
up a model to try and do this
at the bottom left you can see as before
he would put this melanoma into these
mice let it grow for five four weeks
before it would be large enough to be
treated with the radiation therapy but
before that tumor was big enough to get
treated with radiation therapy he would
implant the same melanoma on the other
flank that tumor would be shielded by
the radiation therapy because it would
reflect a small incipient cancer that we
might not be clinically aware of and
therefore not know to irradiated and so
at the time of radiation the large tumor
is irradiated the smaller tumor is not
irradiated and five days later the large
tumor gets the injection of the
immunotherapy we thought we knew what
was going to happen we thought that the
radiation to the large tumor and the
immunotherapy given to the large tumor
would turn on the potent immune response
that I've shown before would make that
tumor shrank would turn on systemic
adaptive immunity that would be able to
go throughout the mouse and kill smaller
tumors wherever they were just like I
showed you that systemic immune response
could protect a mouse from retellings at
that same tumor well that's what we
expected but when we did the experiment
it didn't work that way and I want to
take a little more time to show you the
data here because we were surprised by
this
it was initially quite confusing but we
think it's a major key to how we want to
move forward to make this approach
successful clinically so what we're
showing here in the upper left are the
actual data the solid purple line shows
how if we had only a single tumor in the
mouse and we irradiated that single
tumor and injected it with the
immunotherapy how that tumor goes away
in a mouse treated that way the dashed
line shows what happens to that exact
same tumor that gets the irradiation and
gets treated with the immunotherapy if
that same
has a small untreated tumor in the
distant flank that was sealed by a
radiation so let me say that again the
presence of the distant tumor it wasn't
irradiated and wasn't treated with any
immunotherapy not only doesn't shrink
but it's blocking the immuno therapeutic
effect at the site of the tumor that
gets the radiation and gets the
immunotherapy we find this very
frightening because it says if this kind
of phenomenon is reproduced in other
tumors or is important in clinical
cancer the distant tumors that we might
not even know about can block this
potent immunologic effect and we think
that this is a tolerance effect to
understand it better we asked what the
specificity of this is so we set up this
same model where we tested a mouse that
had a big melanoma that got irradiated
and got immunotherapy but we made the
small tumor on the other side that was
shielded from the radiation the
pancreatic cancer
panco - and what you can see the data
are shown at the bottom the solid purple
line shows how a mouse with only one
tumor that's the melanoma has that tumor
respond if it's treated with radiation
and immunotherapy the dashed purple line
shows what I showed in the previous
experiment namely if that same mouse has
two melanomas one that's irradiated and
injected with immunotherapy and one
that's shielded from radiation the
treated tumor doesn't respond the yellow
line shows this is a specific kind of
tolerance what this says is if the large
tumor that gets a radiation and
immunotherapy if that's melanoma and the
small tumor that's shielded on the other
side and doesn't get any immunotherapy
if that's Mela if that one is the
pancreatic cancer the different kind of
tumor then the melanoma that we treat
with radiation and immunotherapy still
responds in other words something about
that small shielded tumor
crosses throughout the mouse and if the
other tumor is the exact same kind is
the untreated tumor it blocks the immune
response now in data that I don't have
time to show we've showed specificity of
this because we set up the same exact
phenomenon with a mouse that has a large
pancreatic tumor it responds to the
melanoma if we have just one pancreatic
tumor in the mouse if the small separate
tumor is a pancreatic cancer
the big pancreatic cancer won't respond
but if the small separate tumor is a
melanoma the big pancreatic cancer will
respond to min up there so this is a
cancer specific immune tolerance it's
very frightening to us and how might we
potentially overcome it well one thing
we did was set up the same model system
with two melanomas a big one and a small
one irradiate the big one inject the big
one with immunotherapy but also
irradiate the small one and under these
conditions shown with the dotted purple
line even though the immunotherapy is
only going to the big tumor as long as
you were radiate both tumors now the big
tumor responds as shown by the dotted
purple line and so irradiating that
small tumor blocks this concomitant
immune tolerance and that radiation
therapy dose is only 12 great it's not
enough to make that small tumor shrink
so this is a very radiation sensitive
tolerance effect so the fact that it is
so tumor specific and it is also
inhibited by radiation says that this
immune tolerance is specific and
radiation sensitive one component of the
immune response that's very specific and
radiation sensitive are T cells and we
know inhibitory T cells specifically
called T regulatory cells are very
potent at suppressing immune responses
and under certain conditions can
suppress them in a very antigen-specific
way so it's shown on the left is some
proof that that's the mechanism involved
what you can see with this data is
animals that have only one tumor and get
no radiation to that tumor have a fair
number of T regulatory cells in them
that's the gray bar but if we irradiate
that one tumor in these mites and look
six days later the purple bar shows that
we've gotten rid of most of those t
regulatory cells but if you look at that
same tumor in the mouse that has two
tumors and you irradiate that one tumor
with the same amount of radiation and
look at it six days later the tan bar
shows that even though it was irradiated
you still have as many T regulatory
cells as you had before six days after
radiation and it's because of that
distant small tumor that you didn't
irradiate it must be that the T
regulatory cells are migrating from that
small non irradiated tumor to this one
and playing a role in inhibiting the
effect to prove it we did the experiment
at the right these are mice that are
transgenic for a way to deplete their
key regulatory cells they have on their
t regulatory cells a receptor that
responds to the diphtheria toxin what we
did was set up this two tumor model
irradiate the large melanoma inject the
large melanoma with the immunotherapy
and if we don't deplete the T regulatory
cells we got the solid purple line that
treated tumor didn't respond but if we
use the diphtheria toxin to get rid of
the T regulatory cells now that tumor
response as shown by the dotted purple
line and in controls that aren't shown
here if we use diphtheria toxin alone
there's no effect against the tumor so
how might we translate into something
that's more clinically relevant so most
oncologists are today very familiar with
checkpoint blockade the initial
successful molecule
was anti ctla-4 it Bielema map and other
similar agents Allen Corman who devised
and created the clinical form of hippie
luma map is doing a mouse work and we
are collaborating with him in our
studies and he's generated a mouse
appeal uma mAb equivalent one of these
if he live a map molecules does a great
job of blocking ctla4 and it's the red
line and the other does a great job of
blocking ctla4 but it also gets rid of
cells that overexpress ctla-4 and
interestingly T regulatory cells those
inhibitory T cells dramatically
overexpress ctla-4 and this form of
antibody shown in the black line
depletes them and so the data shown in
the graph at the lower right shows if we
take the same two tumor model and we've
got mice that get a radiation to the big
tumor and then get immunotherapy only to
the big tumor if they don't get any
other treatment the big tumor continues
to grow as shown in the purple line if
they get a potent antibody that's great
at blocking ctla4 like the red line that
big tumor still continues to grow even
though we interfered with ctla4 s
inhibitory function but if we use the
antibody that can deplete T regulatory
cells the black line now that big tumor
shrinks away and more importantly shown
on the next slide not only does that big
tumor shrink away but in this same
experiment when we look at the distant
second tumor in those same animals the
black lines show is that that distant
tumor that did not get any radiation
that did not get exposed to any of this
ant IgE to il-2 immuno cytokine that
distant tumor did go away as long as we
depleted the T regulatory cells with the
anti ctla-4 if we look at any other
combination of those agents in these
mites that second tumor didn't go away
so based on this we think very potent
immunotherapy attic effect that we are
reproducing in other tumor models in our
laboratory system but we have published
specifically on this melanoma data we're
excited about moving this forward
so here's very preliminary data showing
how we can reproduce the same effect in
another tumor model here instead of
looking at the b-78 melanoma growing in
a strain of mice called c57 black now
we're looking at a separate kind of
neuroblastoma it also expresses gd2 but
it grows in a separate strain of mice
ajay mice and the graph at the left
shows that the red line is how these
neuroblastoma is grow without any
therapy the green line shows that how
these tumors are slowed a bit by
radiation therapy alone but they
continue to grow the brown line shows
how intra tumor liminal cytokine makes
those tumors grow slower but they still
continue to grow and the red line shows
that the combination of the radiation
and the intramural anti gd2 antibody
il-2 makes those tumors shrink and seven
out of seven mice become completely
cancer-free with a cancer response these
are mice with a single neuroblastoma the
graph on the right shows what happens to
that neuroblastoma that you were radiate
and that you treat with the immuno
cytokine in a mouse that has only one
tumor the red line recapitulating what's
shown in the graph at the left or what
happens to that tumor that you were
radiate and injecting them you know
therapy if that same mouse has a distant
and access to neuroblastoma the treated
tour continues to grow consistent with
the concomitant and intolerance that
we've shown for the b-78 melanoma in a
separate tumor model so conceptually
here's what we think is going on in the
data that I've shown so far we think
that
in trying to get an immune response
against the cancer at the upper left
we've got the innate immune cells that
are recognizing the tumor with antibody
in the middle we've got the adaptive
immune response but t-cells that would
use that T cell receptors to recognize
the antigen and then to the lower left
we've got these immunosuppressive
elements I focused largely on T
regulatory cells we also know that there
are other cells in the tumor
microenvironment that can suppress the
immune response like immunosuppressive
mylord arrived suppressor cells or other
macrophage elements so we think that
radiation therapy can be doing two
things first it can make the tumor more
sensitive to innate immune destruction
and it also can have an effect against
the immunosuppressive tumor
micro-environment shown at the lower
left next we think that that would
enable an antibody io2 immuno cytokine
in order to help innate immune cells
meeting antibody dependent cellular
cytotoxicity against the tumor in order
to cause some destruction of the tumor
that's now more sensitive to this
destruction because of the radiation
therapy enabling that tumor that is
partially being destroyed by that innate
immune response to fragment and still
have coated onto it the monoclonal
anti-tumor antibody which will allow
those antibody coated tumor fragments to
be picked up by the FC receptors of the
antigen presenting cells as shown at the
lower right and those tumor fragments
are then picked up by those antigen
presenting cells and processed to enable
the peptides from that tumor to be able
to be presented by the MHC the HLA
antigens of the antigen presenting cell
to turn on a cytotoxic T lymphocyte
sensitization that activates those T
cells that specifically have receptors
that can recognize the tumor peptides
that are present on the tumor cell not
necess
the ones that are recognized by the
anti-tumor monoclonal antibody put those
into the cleft of the MHC and turn on
the t cells that can recognize them but
then they need to be expanded by the
il-2 that drives those activated cells
to expand to be able to subsequently
expand to a potent cytotoxic T
lymphocyte response that can destroy
tumor not only the site that's
irradiated but at distant sites as well
so we're taking this concept and moving
it forward clinically just two weeks ago
we learned from the US Food and Drug
Administration that our first and human
protocol to test this concept has been
approved by the FDA for testing in
melanoma patients where we're going to
be using a combination of local
radiation therapy intramural anti gd2
immuno cytokine together with anti
ctla-4 and Nivola map for advanced
melanoma we're doing this study and
adults with melanoma here at the
University of Wisconsin and I'm working
together with our clinical melanoma
leader mark Albertini and with our
radiation immuno oncology leader Zack
Morris and as much as the work I've
talked about today is focused on our use
of anti ge2 antibody to have this effect
these concepts should potentially
translate to the use of the anti tumor
reactive monoclonal antibody and il-2 to
be able to have these concepts work for
other kinds of cancer so the last
concept that I want to briefly mention
is I did show before how we can overcome
this tolerance effect by giving low-dose
radiation therapy to all tumor sites the
problem is when we take this concept
clinically patients with cancer can have
metastatic disease at many sites sites
that you can see in sites that you can't
see and if you wanted to actually
deliver low-dose radiation to all of
those sites to black this tumor
immunosuppressive microenvironment you'd
be giving total body radiation which
would be counterproductive because it
would be immunosuppressant so is there a
way to get radiation therapy
just to the cancer and the answer is the
concept of targeted molecular radiation
therapy now in the setting of adult
oncology radio labeled anti-tumor
antibodies have been used particularly
in the setting of lymphoma to
preferentially get radiation therapy
specifically to tumors in the setting of
pediatric oncology i 31 a 131 has been
used as the molecule MIB G to
selectively get radiation therapy to
neuroblastoma we're using this concept
and based on preclinical data that I
really don't have a chance to to show
we're using targeted molecular radiation
therapy to try and overcome this
immunosuppressive effect we're able to
do this in our mouse models where we've
been able to show here in data from Zack
Morris's lab where molecular targeted
radiation therapy shown in black has no
effect by itself where checkpoint
blockade with ctla-4 blockade has no
effect but the combination of them has a
potent effect in mice with this and
access to neuroblastoma
so we're moving this into a clinical
trial that has now opened at the
combined site in the United Kingdom of
Southampton in London led by our
colleague Juliet gray and mark gaze this
is going to be an international trial
that will also open in graceful wild
Germany led by our colleague Holger
Lotte who's done pioneering work showing
how nivolumab can and synergistically
they anti GE to immunotherapy to get
better a DCC and together with my
colleague Ken De Santis who's our
division head and our MIB G leader here
in Madison to use this together with our
anti gd2 immunotherapy so this trial
so-called the minivan trial is going to
take these patients with high-risk
relapsed neuroblastoma and treat them
with radioactive mi B G to get targeted
radiotherapy to them to use anti gd2
monoclonal antibody and to combine this
with checkpoint blockade in the
of Nivola map so it's open in London it
should be open soon in Madison and in
graceful so that's the science I wanted
to present we have many many
collaborators that are working on this
approach I've tried to mention many of
the collaborators at our UW Cancer
Center in the upper left
I mentioned the collaborators in this
international neuroblastoma trial at the
lower left
we've got collaborators working through
the Children's Oncology Group at st.
Jude our industrial collaborators
include Steve gillies who work with the
Ralph Riceville to make these anti
jeanne 2 molecules BMS providing
checkpoint blockade and a peer on and us
a to providing the forms of the anti gd2
reagents or the checkpoint blockade so
in order to do this work of course we
need grant support and we've got the
good fortune of having support from a
variety of funding agencies enabling us
to do the basic the preclinical
translation and the clinical trials and
my last slide just shows patients that
have all been treated here in our Center
for pediatric cancers here at the
University of Wisconsin every five years
we have a reunion of these patients we
have a mailing list of approaching 1500
such patients who've been cured to their
pediatric cancers and these patients
have been cured over the last 25 to 30
years largely using therapies that were
being pioneered is preclinical work in
the 70s and 80s largely chemotherapy but
over the past 20 years immunotherapy is
clearly having a potent effect in the
setting of both pediatric and adult
cancers we believe with less toxic
effects with less long-term genotoxic
damage and hopefully with better results
in fewer long-term side effects so we
are hoping that the future is going to
look bright by applying the immuno
therapeutic principles in combination
therapies that can activate both innate
and adaptive immune responses so thanks
very much I'll end it there and open it
up to questions
thank you doctor Sandow for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click the send button our speakers
will follow up with your questions via
email now let's get started our first
question is is this approach only
directed towards neuroblastoma and
Mellon melanoma so many people ask this
after I've presented the data because
much of our clinical application has
focused initially on neuroblastoma the
anti gd2 antibody approaches were
working with have largely been directed
against both neuroblastoma and melanoma
but many other cancers including both
pediatric and adult sarcoma such as
osteosarcoma Ewing sarcoma
rhabdomyosarcoma can express gd2 in
addition some lung cancers expressed gd2
so provided that patients express GE too
on their cancers the approach that we've
been working with using anti gd2
monoclonal antibodies should be
applicable but as I mentioned most
patients with cancer have cancers that
express molecules that are recognized by
separate monoclonal antibodies that have
either been already approved for
clinical use such as anti cd20 or anti
EGF AR or anti F cam or anti her2 or
have cancers for which monoclonal
antibodies are currently in clinical
testing and are likely soon to be
approved for standard use sexted in the
future
virtually all cancers should be
recognizable by clinically available
monoclonal antibodies and the kind of
approaches that we've been working on
pre clinically we think would help those
monoclonal antibodies to be used in
common
issue with regimens that would activate
innate immune recognition ADCC in a way
that could be coupled with subsequent
adaptive immune recognition to get the
kind of memory responses we're hoping to
turn on and what antigens might this
incite to vaccine approach be utilizing
so this is an important question that
we're studying in data that I was not
able to show when we turn on memory
responses in mice that have gotten this
combined adaptive innate immune
combination therapy and where we've used
an anti g2 antibody to turn on that
memory response we show the mice that
are cured can reject other melanomas
that don't have gd2 on them so even
though the antibody that's used to
recognize the tumor initially and turn
on the initial innate response seems to
be key in this response the antigens are
recognized by the adaptive response by
the t-cells I'm not the same ones that
are recognized by the antibody and they
can be a variety of molecules who are
just in the process of studying our
hypothesis is that two kinds of tumor
related antigens might be very important
one would be those neo antigens that are
controlled by some of the mutations that
are inherent in virtually any cancer
some cancers like lung cancers in
melanoma as many of those neo antigens
because they have a high tumor mutation
burden other cancers like neuroblastoma
have a very low neo antigen load because
of a low tumor mutation burden but their
neo antigens might still be targets but
those don't have to be the only targets
we know from past immunotherapy work
such as the pioneering work of Steve
Rosenberg at the NCI or Terry boon in
Europe that some of the most potent
antigens recognized on human cancers
aren't antigens controlled by mutated
genes but are antigens the
controlled by molecules that are
expressed only on stem cells around
cancer testes molecules molecules that
are not expressed by normal cells for
the most part but only cells early in
their differentiation but are highly
over expressed by cancer cells molecules
like Mart or mage or other similar kinds
of maladies it looks like we're gonna
have time for one more question
what other agents might combine well
with this immunotherapy approach we're
studying that and we think that many
other agents might combine and we've got
some preliminary data in mice that
suggests that this kind of approach
might be applicable for using not only
antibodies linked dial to as fusion
proteins but for anti-tumor antibodies
and il-2 has separate molecules in
addition we've got some data saying that
approaches that can activate better
function of antigen presenting cells can
help turn on a better immune response
molecules like anti cd4 T these could be
able to work in addition there may be
some benefit of using selective
chemotherapy that might actually not
cause suppression of the immune system
but help augment antigen presentation
and suppress the tumor microenvironment
and finally as I mentioned we're really
here to become combining this with
targeted molecular radiotherapy all
right well I would like to once again
thank dr. Sandow for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know if that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January of 2019 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay be sure that announcement with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon
by